MAJOR HOPING FOR A REAL LIFE.
I REALIZE I AM IN A GROWN-UP
LIFE WITH TAXES, BILLS, AND
BRATS.
THAT WORD WAS PICKED BECAUSE
DUST DWELLING MEDIA TYPES BEAT
IT TO DEATH.
SPEAK OF THE EXTANT SHOW SCANDAL
HAS SURROUNDED THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY.
IT'S BECAUSE HE IS AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO THOSE
AMERICAN VALUES.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS SUCH AN X
ESSENTIAL THREAT TO OUR
DEMOCRACY.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS AN X
ESSENTIAL THREAT TO THE FUTURE
OF THE UNITED STATES FOR ITS
BECAUSE HE HAS AN X ESSENTIAL
THREAT TO THE COUNTRY.
BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE IT WAS
EXISTENTIAL.
THEY NEED TO UNSEAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP PAID >> Greg:
SOMEONE FACIAL GOOD NEWS, JUST
CALL TRUMP AN EXISTENTIAL
THREAT.
IN ABSENCE OF A REAL PHYSICAL
THREAT WHICH IS A PSYCHOLOGICAL
ONE.
JUST LOOK AT ALL OF THE
MEASURABLE SEPARATE ECONOMY,
JOBS, TARIFFS, YOU SEE NUMBERS
TRENDING POSITIVELY.
THAT LEAVES THE MEDIA WHICH IS
ONE OPTION.
PUSH THINGS THAT CAN'T BE
MEASURED TO PREDICT GLOOM AND
GLOOM.
IF MEMBER, NONE OF THESE
SMARTY-PANTS ON THE INTERNET HAS
AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO DICTION
EYES OR EVEN BOTHERED UP TO LOOK
UP THE WORD IN THE DICTIONARY
BUT HERE THEY ARE DESPERATELY
COMPETING FOR ATTENTION WHILE
THE WHOLE PLANET IGNORES THEM,
WHICH IS WHY THE OXFORD
DICTIONARIES TO CLIMATE
EMERGENCY AS ITS WORD OF THE
YEAR.
EVEN I THINK IT'S TWO.
OXFORD SAID ITS USE TO FILL THE
STOMACH REFLECT THE MOOD OR
PREOCCUPATIONS OF THE PAST YEAR.
TRANSITION, IT'S WHAT RICH
ELITES SAY AS THEY BOARD A PLANE
FOR A HOLIDAY IN FRANCE.
I REMEMBER WHEN DICTIONARIES
WERE AWESOME AND THEY CONTAINED
WORDS NOT THE POLITICS OF
PRETENTIOUS EDITORS.
NOW THEY ARE JUST LIKE EVERY
OTHER MEDIUM FULL OF ANXIOUS
SOCIAL CLIMBERS, STRAINING FOR
UNLIKE ME.
EXISTENTIAL.
IT VERY OVERUSED TERM,
EXISTENTIAL CREATED >>
EXISTENTIAL.
>> EXISTENTIAL.
>> Greg: AT LEAST I KNEW WHAT
IT MEANT.
>> Katie: I WOULDN'T HAVE
THOUGHT YOU SAID IT THAT MUCH.
I THINK BACK WHEN ISIS WAS
BEHEADING PEOPLE, I WAS CALLINGI
BEHEADING PEOPLE, I WAS CALLING
BEHEADING PEOPLE, I WAS CALLINGN
BEHEADING PEOPLE, I WAS CALLINGE
BEHEADING PEOPLE, I WAS CALLINGI
BEHEADING PEOPLE, I WAS CALLINGT
BEHEADING PEOPLE, I WAS CALLINGN
BEHEADING PEOPLE, I WAS CALLINGI
BEHEADING PEOPLE, I WAS CALLINGL
THREAT BUT IT TOLD THEM TO
LOOK IT UP BECAUSE I AM NOT A
HYPOCRITE.
JUAN?
>> Juan: CHECK IT OUT.
>> Greg: >> Juan: 22, IS
THERE A WORD OF THE YEAR THAT
YOU WOULD THINK OF?
>> Juan: I SAW THERE WAS SOME
THOUGHT ABOUT CULTURE BECAUSE I
HADN'T HEARD THAT ONE THIS YEAR.
I WILL SAY THOUGH THAT ON THE
SUBSTANCE OF THIS, I SAW THAT IN
THE REPORT ISSUED TODAY, THE
DEMOCRATS CALLED TRUMP AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO THE RULE
OF LAW AND THE CONSTITUTION
CREATED >> Katie: YOU KNOW
WHAT WORD SHOULD HAVE BEEN THE
WORD OF THE YEAR?
TRUMP BECAUSE YOU DECIDED AND
EXISTENTIAL IN THE SAME
SENTENCE.
IF EVERYONE SAYS TRUMP 5 MILLION
TIMES A DAY.
>> Greg: IT'S LIKE THE
WEATHER.
IT'S LIKE TRUMP HAS REPLACED THE
IT >> Katie: IT'S A NOUN THEM,
OR A VERB, EVEN, OR AN AGITATED.
IT'S LIKE ALL OF THE THINGS,
THAT'S THE WORD THEY SHOULD'VE
CHOSEN.
>> Greg: NONEGGHEADS LIKE
YOU --
>> Jesse: YOU KNOW WHAT I
HEARD A LOT THIS WEEKEND?
DISNEY PLUS.
DO YOU HAVE DISNEY BLESS?
DID YOU SIGN UP FOR DISNEY PLUS?
I HEARD THAT EVERYBODY IS
TALKING ABOUT DISNEY PLUS.
I'M NOT GETTING PAID BY IT AS A
PLUS BUT I'M JUST SAYING, FULL
DISCLOSURE, THAT'S WHAT EVERYONE
IS TALKING ABOUT.
>> Greg: I THINK I GOT DISNEY
PLUS FROM GOOFY.
A LOT OF ANTIBIOTICS.
JANA, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
DO YOU HAVE A THEORY?
>> Dana: I THINK THIS IS ONE
OF THE REASONS THEY DIDN'T WIN
AND TRUMP DID WHEN THREAT HE
USES VERY PLAIN LANGUAGE THAT
EVERYONE CAN UNDERSTAND.
HE SAID HILLARY CLINTON WILL
DESTROY AMERICA AND HE SAID IT
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND
THEY ARE SAYING DONALD TRUMP IS
AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO
AMERICA.
IF IT DOESN'T HAVE THE SAME
PUNCH.
YOU HAVE TO KNOW HOW TO USE THE
LANGUAGE AND THIS WHOLE THING --
THE DICTIONARY EVERY YEAR
REMINDS ME OF THE PERSON OF THE
YEAR THAT THEY WILL PICK THINGS
THAT WILL HELP THEM GET EARNED
MEDIA FROM THEIR PEERS SO THAT
WE WILL THEN TALK ABOUT IT AND
MAKE FUN OF THEM ON "THE FIVE."
>> Greg: EXACTLY AND EVERYBODY
WRITES FOR THE OTHER PERSON IN
THE INDUSTRY.
A >> Dana: TOTALLY BEAR THE
THING I WOULD CANCEL HIS IT'S
NOT A WORD, IT'S THAT THING ON
TWITTER.
IT'S I'M NOT CRYING, YOU'RE
CRYING?
STOP.
I CAN'T TAKE THAT.
>> Greg: I JUST CAN'T.
I JUST CAN'T.
YOU KNOW IT'S COMMON?
EVERYBODY SAYS 100% INSTEAD OF
ABSOLUTELY OR RIGHT.
THEY JUST SAY --
>> Dana: I JUST SAY HUNDRED.
WHAT ABOUT HONDO P?
100%?
THAT'S THE YOUNG PEOPLE.
WE DO HERE'S THE THING TO IT
UNDER THE WORD OF THE AIR, USE
IT IN A SENTENCE.
Dictionary.com TO CHECK THIS
OUT.
IT SAYS DOES CLIMATE CHANGE POSE
AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO
HUMANITY?
THEY ARE POLITICIZING
EVERYTHING, INCLUDING THE
DICTIONARY.
>> Greg: I'M TELLING YOU RIGHT
NOW, GRETA THORNBURGH IS GOING
TO BE A PERSON OF THE ON "TIME"
MAGAZINE GRID I'M CALLING IT.
SPEECHES ARE NEXT OUTCOME OF THE
HOLIDAY EXERCISE BIKE THAT IS
SPARKING ACCUSATION OF SEXISM
AND MORE.
STAY TUNED.